my experience really was just about a
psychological abuse where I felt I was
going mad Allen's abuser was his wife
for years he suffered alone she bullied
and belittled him and when he finally
tried to get help he was ignored I was
thinking I ought to be able to handle
this situation I ought to be able to
have sort this situation out I ought to
be able to make the marriage work when I
made a complaint to the police about my
wife I was laughed out by the officer
who came round Allen believes this was
because he was a man he feels male
victims of domestic abuse for too long
have been sidelined and silenced
official figures show one in three
domestic abuse victims is a man that's
around 450,000 victims in the UK per
year but the real figure could be much
higher with men twice more likely than
women to hide the abuse they are
suffering and fewer places where men
specifically can get help
campaigners say this has to change a
very common experience is for a man to
be forced to leave his home even with
family and have nowhere to go other than
to a homeless hostel or to the streets
and when you look at the the reasons for
homelessness and violent relationship
breakdowns are one of the major reasons
why men become homeless and even rough
sleeping and that scandalous it really
should not happen in 2019 it's a
freezing morning in Liverpool not an
ideal place for a swim or a typical
place to talk about male domestic abuse
we wanted to highlight domestic abuse
ridden man they were set up and sippy
for our crime a pearler we lost haddock
circumstances their mate Paul died after
being attacked by his girlfriend they
discovered he'd been a victim of
domestic abuse repeatedly but was too
embarrassed to say our friend a beer
today Paula well he loved this boy
he's Nadia and it's not recognized the
tackler - later Paul another man and it
should be it's wrong and need to stop
a swim can't bring back their friend but
it can bring men together to talk to
tackle the stigma for male survivors and
help them help themselves
Katerina ever taught see Sky News in
Liverpool